so the divine comedy at the end
is
the victory
of god
at the end of the poem
we witness god conquering
that's what he wants us to see
dante is granted a vision of a point
about which a great
dance of angels swirls
beatrice talking about this point that
he sees out of which his shooting light
calls it the point on which everything
depends
and this is dante's glimpse at the end
of the nine heavens of god himself
and that description the point
on which everything depends
is famous
and i think it's worth thinking about
for a moment together if you go all the
way back to the inferno and then all the
way forward to this point the point
of the comedy
here now
is that everything depends on god
if we think back to the inferno
everything there depended on what
the will or the judgment of the lost
in purgatory the souls
learned to
depend to lean on god again
and now here it's stated directly right
on the brink of the heaven of heavens
beatrice says that is the point
on which everything depends
at this point in the poem haha the point
is overwhelming to dante's eyes and as
dante begins to make the transition to
the 10th level to the emperian
he speaks of it
in kanto 30.
he says on line 10 for example
the triumph of the choirs who feast
forever about the point that conquered
me
that seems embraced by what it has
embraced
vanished from my vision gradually
so that i turned my eyes to beatrice
compelled by love
and by no more to see
so dante trying to look at this point
can't
you may think of the eclipses that
happen they say don't look at that
little point it'll blind you
um
but that description there the point
that conquered me
if god is the point
on which everything depends in the
divine comedy
this line is
foreshadowing the end of the poem
god is the point
that conquers dante in this poem
you